previously on TV since this is
hand-stitched embroidery from an
indigenous tribe in Guatemala that's
almost extinct so they're not gonna go
mama
holy is this the unholy return of frisky
dingo on FX
I thought Cartoon Network cancelled that
because people were getting too high to
watch it which has to be some
catastrophic bar to reach what you're
talking about the Cartoon Network
sterling Archer
known from Berlin to Bangkok is the
world's most dangerous spy we're
starting off with some good
old-fashioned torturous position so we
can clearly understand who Archer is
right out of the gate and these may be
old cliche but they have this of making
you talk
admitting it doesn't excuse it even when
you're and a bad guy is conducting an
audience fake outz emulation but later
turns out to be the actual bad guy
anyway situation what is the point of
these simulations discount lucille bluth
would be excellent at TV sets
seriously that what good is a torture
simulation when you obviously aren't
going to torture anyone apparently
you've gone so far as to paint on exact
replicas of rambo first blood scars so
how is this a good use of anyone's time
chosen at random by the ISIS computer
picking a name in a cartoon for your
secret organization that will one day be
known by everyone in the real world as a
terrorist organization is classic Archer
is it anyone else bothered by how
archers cleft in his chin looks to of
achieve full bifurcation I mean a chin
dimple is one thing but chin cleavage is
something completely different totally
get if the show didn't want to have to
get any sponsors for their animated
vending machines but could they at least
make it appear as if they have actual
product in them I had to pause this
scene for quite a while and do lots of
close examination but I've determined
that this ping-pong paddle is not only
larger than the mark it left not that it
would be just about impossible to also
leave a mark for the handle what this is
the job people I do it for you
also this answering machine apparently
has no power cords or phone lines TV
show doesn't even know how to answering
machine also also let's see anything
else on the screen mmm she's wearing a
hat which I guess is possible but
certainly her makeup wouldn't still be
so pristine
yeah the makeup thing okay fine let's
move on if I find one single dog here
when I get back I'll rub sand in your
dead little eyes very good sir
I also need you to go by San yes oh this
might be one of the best written shows
in the history of TV take your cinema a
few clever bastards one entire whole
week leaving calling you considering
we're about to find out this is the
secret entrance of his agency how has
this even been an issue isn't he there
quite a bit also
and for dry cleaner employees to just be
standing at the counter holding your
shirts when they see you walking in
highly unprofessional really because I
find your sweatiness unprofessional
that's first burst the fact that we
don't get more about these obvious
identical blond mustache twins working
in the same Department side-by-side
every day is absolutely a sin I'm not
asking for a spinoff I'm just asking for
a one-off episode of how Gordon and
Griffin here moonlight as magician
assistants every Thursday night at the
local club blonde illusions is that too
much to ask
I remember that Lana is just a cartoon
remember that Lana's just a cartoon
remember that Lana's just a cartoon
remember that what is this smell like
like the dysfunctional [ __ ] I broke
up with six months ago skip what
happened was um did you see Brian's song
same thing pretty much happen taking
Brian's song in vain is isn't your own
personal travel agency it doesn't exist
just so you can jet off to [ __ ] island
that's not a real place except that it
is and it's airing on CBS all access
every freaking day of the week love
island my ass I've got your all access
right here CBS oh good you caught the oh
wait I I had something for this the PETA
predator I mean
PETA file was right there man but Krispy
creamer I'm just saying you had choices
if you want some food that's supposed to
be cream-filled I offer these delicious
donuts got a mother Dunkin donut place
just piles the donuts on top of each
other like that you monsters the first
at street level impenetrable after 6:00
fun fact impenetrable after 6:00 was the
nickname I gave my college girlfriend
which sucks because I worked until 6:00
like every day the second through an
access door on the roof inexplicably
unprotected Archer would be amazing at
TVs wait a minute that's almost sort of
the point isn't it for a zipline to work
it cannot have this amount of slack
otherwise you're just asking to pull a
girls trip with your pinkett-smith just
hanging out there in the middle for all
to see what the hell is going on with
archers tiny hand here when he turns it
over it goes full denieth mahara also
the show is now telling us the mouse
that was in archers mind when he was
telling the story to Cheryl is actually
in the room Archer have dreamscape
powers I think Arthur has [ __ ]
dreamscape powers how did I spend that
much money good question considering
that an expense account shouldn't allow
you to overspend to such an insane -
great man especially since you have do
good or Cyril watching all the money
these are
black Oh are they I'm with the can of
mixed vegetables here of considering the
one he's wearing right now has a
distinct blue hue to it is blue right oh
god I just had flashbacks about arguing
about that stupid internet dress and
that alone is worth this sin I'm the
mole idiot what I made up the mole yes
but you told Pam and now everyone is
looking for a real mole are they
absolutely no one has been looking for a
mole lana was back at her place waiting
for Cyril to make her a stir-fry this
organization is so bad that there's
absolutely no way any agents were
looking for a mole especially to the
point that this dude felt any heat
whatsoever picture her dead in the gun
and what your pathetic life will be like
without old mommy dearest clothes hanger
trauma sorry wrong IP no just half of
one
Johnny Bench called I know we already
took a sin off for how funny this show
us but I'm just gonna take another sin
off for the running Johnny Bench called
joke because it is amazing do you want
ants because that's how you get it's
quite possible this is the moment T V
sins was born I'll leave it up to you to
decide if that's a sin or not
I don't like sound its coarse rough and
irritating mr. powers miss shag when
welcome to my hollow dead volcano my
code was chosen at random by the Isis
computer random it was your dog's name
renamed the dog Indiana is that Archer
hot damn it Archer go away
may I suggest messily eating an orange
while I photograph it good day sir hey
wait what about your I said good day in
the summertime where the weather is hot
you can step right up and get a sandwich
that's God can we please have one
conversation that's not about my rack
Michael
Johnny Bench called that's a veiled
criticism about me I won't hear it and I
won't respond to it